there are plenty of great
underappreciated movie trilogies to dive
into whether they're small Indies or
movies you love but didn't realize we're
part of a trilogy for your next lazy
Sunday settle in pull up your favorite
streaming service and fall in love with
a new three-part film series directed by
Richard Linklater this trilogy spans
continents decades and takes a deep look
at the changing nature of longtime
relationships before sunrise finds Jesse
and Celine locking eyes on a train and
experiencing one long night in Vienna
filled with revelations deep connections
and love at first sight the second film
before sunset focuses on the compromises
and changes you make in your 30s as
Jesse and Celine reconnect after 9 years
apart
it's relationship when it ends with
advantageously I never fully recover
that's why I'm very careful with getting
involved because it hurts too much
before midnight jumps ahead another 9
years after that threw Jesse and Celine
long and passionate love story nearly
every viewer will be able to find at
least one striking similarity to their
own life el Mariachi follows an
out-of-work musician simply known as el
Mariachi who's mistaken for a ruthless
criminal by murderous gang unbeknownst
to many fans it's also the first film of
a trilogy that includes the far more
popular desperado and Once Upon a Time
in Mexico part of that confusion comes
down to recasting Carlos Gallardo's
played el Mariachi in the first film but
he was replaced by Antonio Banderas for
the final two films together the three
films showcase all the over-the-top
violence and melodrama that any Robert
Rodriguez fan could ask for
based on Stieg Larsson's series about a
vengeful young hacker named Lisbeth
Salander this film franchise originally
aired on Swedish channel SBT 1 as a
miniseries though each installment
totaled around 3 hours each the first
film The Girl with the Dragon Tattoo
introduces us the Salander who is
helping disgrace journalist Mikael
investigate a missing person throughout
the next two films the girl who played
with fire and The Girl Who Kicked the
hornets nest McHale and Salander
continue working together and when
Salander is wrongly accused of murdering
a journalist who was targeting Mikael he
works to prove her innocence the
Hannibal Lecter trilogy features other
films and adaptations beyond these three
films but these installments make up the
core of the
franchise based on the series of novels
by Thomas Harris the film adaptations
begin with the Silence of the Lambs
starring Jodie Foster is Clarice and
Anthony Hopkins as Hannibal Lecter the
story finds its unlikely partners
teaming up to track down another
sadistic serial killer known as Buffalo
Bill the film is in arguably a classic
when he nearly half a dozen Oscar Awards
in 1992 was some of the most memorable
dialogue in film history a census taken
once tied to test me I ate his liver
with some fava beans and a nice Chianti
Hopkins reprised his role in Hannibal
but Julianne Moore took over as Clarice
red dragon saw Hopkins returned for a
third and final time bringing all his
considerable charisma to the role of the
cannibal doctor there are technically
six films in George a Romero's Night of
the Living Dead film series but the
first three are regarded as their own
independent trilogy although the three
originals don't share characters they
all take place in the midst of a zombie
outbreak 1968 s Night of the Living Dead
focuses on a group of seven people
trapped in a remote Pennsylvania
farmhouse which is surrounded by Living
Dead it's a true horror classic and one
of the most influential films ever made
Dawn of the Dead released in 1978 was a
collaboration between Romero and Italian
horror filmmaker Dario Argento like its
predecessor it was filmed in
Pennsylvania on an incredibly low budget
and was critically adored becoming one
of the best-known zombie films of the
20th century finally Day of the Dead
arrived in 1985 telling the story of
human survival in underground cities and
bunkers as the infestation continued
each film in the trilogy left a lasting
impact spawning countless remakes
parodies and homage is for years to come
in 2004 director Edgar Wright teamed up
with Simon Pegg and Nick Frost for Shaun
of the Dead
Arai hillarious take on a typical zombie
flick
next came their wonderfully absurd cop
parody Hot Fuzz in 2007 finally the
world's end their take on aliens and the
apocalypse arrived in 2013
completing the Cornetto trilogy the
trilogy's name comes from the famous
british frozen treat and each film
features a different color of Cornetto
which relates to its plot red for Shaun
of the Dead blue for Hot Fuzz and green
for the World's End though none of the
films share the same universe watching
each of them back-to-back
the obscures the chance the spot plenty
of jokes and references I'm taking a
shortcut before what's the matter Danny
you've never taken a shortcut the show
[Music]